und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend in allen zu einem kurzen
heute journal sie reden miteinander das
ist besser als nichts es ist zugleich
das einzig echte ergebnis nach dem
treffen des russischen außenministers
mit seinem amerikanischen kollegen
europa speziell die menschen in der
ukraine haben heute mit sorge nach genf
geschaut jedes diplomatische wort
gewogen und die zeit gestoppt am ende
stand 90 minuten deutlich weniger als
geplant aber wie gesagt besser als
nichts gunnar krüger
die welt blickt nach genf doch der
winkel leicht ab zwischen washington und
moskau
linke nennt russland einen aggressors
notiert live ein grimme sender und
berichtet dann über die waffen des
westens für osteuropa dialektik das ist
die methode eine behauptung mit ihrem
gegenteil in frage zu stellen sergei
lavrov ist darin großmeister den vorwurf
von anti blinken russland denke wie im
kalten krieg in einflusszonen kontert er
durch studiobosse stimmt nicht was die
nato in der ukraine messen das zeigt
eindeutig dass sie die ukraine als ihre
einzelpersonen betrachtet sowohl für
diese rhetorik gibt genf die kulisse die
stadt der see wie passend an der teck
stunden und ein halbes zugeständnis
nicht in der sache aber in der form frau
in kassel beraten mit unseren partnern
und legen nächste woche dann unsere
sorgen und ideen detailliert und
schriftlich vor
sorgen sorgen sorgen unsere sorge geht
nicht erfunden gefahren sondern fakten
der westen pumpt die ukraine mit waffen
aus juni um erfundene gefahren russische
truppen auf dem weg ins verbündete
belarus senden auch heute ein anderes
bild in die welt
florian hat für uns die gespräche
verfolgt guten amt nach genf ist denn
florian ein möglicher russische
einmarsch in der ukraine mit dem
heutigen tag weniger wahrscheinlich
geworden
für diese frage müsste man wohl in die
glaskugel schauen oder besser doch in
das gehirn von wladimir putin man kann
andererseits sagen das ist heute
durchaus positive signale gab grund für
einen gewissen optimismus beide seiten
nämlich haben betont dass sie weiter
reden wollen und das hat man zuletzt vom
russischen außenminister sergej lawrow
eben noch nicht gehört andererseits gab
es genauso viel grund für pessimismus
denn weiterhin gibt es keine signale der
deeskalation von russischer seite und
insofern ist die große frage wie wird
russland reagieren wenn die usa wie
gerade gehört eben nächste woche diese
antworten schicken auf die russischen
forderungen weiter hin ist nämlich klar
dass der westen nicht eingehen wird auf
russische forderungen etwa nato soldaten
aus nato staaten in osteuropa abzuziehen
das ist schlechterdings nicht
vorstellbar und dann könnte es entweder
zu einem dialog kommen auch auf
präsidenten ebene zwischen beiden und
putin oder es könnte zu der befürchteten
eskalation kommen also möglicherweise
dem einmarsch in die ukraine ich würde
sagen man hat sich heute etwas zeit
gekauft mehr aber auch nicht die analyse
live auskennt von florian ein dankeschön
zwangloses kennenlernen mit einigem
rotwein zu späterer stunde
so stellt man sich klausurtagungen
generell vor auch die der
bundesregierung und so sind die häufig
wohl auch gewesen sagten die die dabei
waren danach die erste klausur des neuen
kabinetts war allerdings heute
nachmittag schon vorbei sie fand im
kanzleramt statt und sie sollte das
zeichen senden es gibt viel zu tun die
zeiten sind nicht nach gemütlichem
beisammensein heike slansky
es dauert einen kurzen moment bis alle
an diesem verschneiten tag in berlin
ihren platz gefunden haben nach sechs
wochen im amt die erste klausurtagung
der regierung mit obligatorischen
gruppenbild mit kanzler der neue
hausherr hatte geladen um aufs tempo zu
drücken wir werden uns beschäftigen mit
dem ganz großen ehrgeizigen vorhaben
dieser regierung dafür zu sorgen dass
wir ein klimaneutrales industrieland
werden denn es geht um die großen linien
um die weichenstellungen um die ressort
übergreifende abstimmung habeck hatte
sich gestern erst eine abfuhr in bayern
geholt dort denke man nicht daran
abstandsregeln für mehr windräder zu
reduzieren auch intern gibt es
widerstand klimaschutz ja sagt die
umweltministerin aber nicht auf kosten
des naturschutzes und der artenvielfalt
mann ist schlau macht wenn man
technische innovation mit nimmt aber
auch wenn man den mut zur politischen
entscheidung aufbringt mal ein paar alte
zöpfe abzuschneiden dass man schneller
werden kann ohne die schutzgüter zu
schädigen und das ist die aufgabe
möglichst win win situation für die
verschiedenen bereiche die er geschützt
sind aus guten grund geschützte und
herzustellen ohne als volkswirtschaft
eingeschlafene füße zu bekommen unser
land ist gefesselt wir haben uns selbst
gefesselt durch sehr viel bürokratie
durch selbst gegebenes recht durch die
umsetzung von europäischem recht in ganz
besonderer deutscher weise auch thema
deutschlands g7 vorsitz seit anfang des
jahres das ziel gemeinsam mit anderen
ländern der welt den klimawandel
aufzuhalten
wir wollen erreichen dass nicht jedes
land für sich alleine geht sondern dass
sie sich zusammentun zu einem klima club
in dem auf unterschiedliche weise aber
gemeinsam voran gekommen wird damit wir
es schaffen die man neutral in der welt
zu werden aufbruch hat die ampel
regierung versprochen in den nächsten
sechs monaten sollen vorzeigbare
ergebnisse vorliegen
jenseits aller kabinetts klausuren prägt
natürlich weiter eine zahl dieses land
und damit beginnt jetzt hat ja die zahl
der neu gemeldeten corona fälle in
deutschland ist erneut stark gestiegen
die sieben tage incidents liebt erstmals
über 700 das robert koch institut meldet
140.000 160 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden das den 47
1937 mehr als vergangenen freitag
170 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents 700
6,3
nach den enthüllungen zum sexuellen
missbrauch im erzbistum münchen und
freising fordern politiker
opfervertreter und katholische laien
eine vollständige aufklärung aus dem
justizministerium hieß es die
aufarbeitung sei keine innere
angelegenheit der kirche
der gesetzliche mindestlohn in
deutschland soll zum ersten oktober auf
12 eur steigen das hat arbeitsminister
heil angekündigt mehrere millionen
beschäftigte sollen davon profitieren
derzeit liegt der gesetzliche
mindestlohn bei 9 eur 82
überschattet von einem innerparteilichen
richtungsstreit hat die partei die linke
nach zweitägiger fraktionsklausur ihren
kurs für die parlamentarische arbeit
bestimmt fraktionschef bartsch kündigte
an als kämpferische opposition für
soziale themen einzutreten dazu zählten
armut steigende energiepreise und mieten
zudem kritisierten sie die ampel pläne
viele würden weiterhin in armut leben
müssen
eine meldung vom tennis alexander zverev
steht bei den australian open im
achtelfinale
durch einen dreisatzsieg gegen den
qualifikanten radio award aus moldau um
den einzug ins viertelfinale spielt der
teles olympiasieger nun gegen den
kanadier delitzsch ab ávalos und es gibt
eine unwetterwarnung des deutschen
wetterdienstes vor starkem schneefall
von mitternacht an für regionen im süden
bayerns die aussichten insgesamt für
morgen im nordosten länger freundlich
sonst meist grau mit etwas sprühregen
oberhalb von etwa 600 metern schlägt vor
allem am alpenrand länger andauernde und
ergiebige schneefälle 0 bis 8 grad in
den nächsten tagen im süden und westen
wieder häufiger sonne sonst meist trübe
aber nur noch vereinzelt etwas regen
oder schnee wie nicht
temperaturänderungen und
damit verabschieden wir uns von ihnen
bis morgen wenn sie mögen und wir alle
müssen abschied nehmen für immer von
einem dessen leben und dessen stimme
ganz große oper waren
meat loaf ist tot der meister des
popchors dessen monumentale balladen und
rock arien zu den erfolgreichsten musik
kunst werken aller zeiten gehören
[Applaus]
manchmal bitte ich um stille hat er
gesungen manchmal bete ich um soul an
manchen tagen bete ich auch einfach zum
gott von sex und drugs und rock'n'roll
[Musik]
sein alter hat der rock'n'roller immer
gern ein bisschen gelassen
meat loaf marvin lee aday wurde so heißt
es 74 jahre alt
[Musik]